now to another story breaking overnight
dramatic cell phone video shows the
frantic moments after a roller coaster
derailed in Florida officials say two
riders fell from the front car dropping
more than 30 feet to the ground
the derailment sent six people to the
hospital last night Manuel Bojorquez is
in Daytona Beach where that coaster
reportedly has had some safety issues in
the past and well good morning good
morning you can still see behind me one
of the cars dangling off the track
officials tell us they had to rescue ten
people from the disabled sandblaster
roller coaster last night it's a well
known attraction here along Daytona
Beach especially during the summer but a
local news report claims it had a spotty
maintenance record one which could have
contributed to this derailment screams
from both eyewitnesses and victims can
be heard as panicked onlookers watched
riders of this derailed Florida roller
coaster plead for help people can be
seen rushing to the aid of riders some
helplessly dangling from the coasters
cars there was ten riders on this chain
of three cars two of which fell out of
the front car to the ground from
approximately a 34 foot height
the other two were dangling from the
front car two of the victims were
transported as trauma alerts possibly
indicating the severity of their
injuries others were loaded into
ambulances and rushed to local hospitals
we just hear a big loud boom and we just
take off run everybody start screaming
and we ran over there and saw the cart
dangling
the sandblaster has been a fixture on
the Daytona Beach boardwalk since 2013
but a report by the Daytona Beach News
Journal revealed the ride was sidelined
last year after a state inspector
discovered more than a dozen safety
violations despite those reported
violations it's not yet clear if they
played any part in the derailment it was
chaotic as you can imagine the riders
were very frightened and the
firefighters were doing a great job of
trying to make sure that everyone stayed
calm investigators will be looking at
those maintenance records as well as
several different factors out here as
they try to narrow down an exact cause
we reached out to the operator of the
roller coaster for a comment but have
not yet heard back John Manuel thanks
harrowing